take a photo and come back completely
autonomously
the communicators monday at 8 eastern on
c-span 2.
up next on american history tv heather
cox richardson author of to make men
free a history of the republican party
she chronicles the evolution of the
party of lincoln and examines the
origins of the party in the slaveholding
south arguing it was founded to advocate
for the middle class against the elite
plantation owners
ms richardson also looks at the
republican figures who defined the party
like presidents abraham lincoln theodore
roosevelt and ronald reagan
the national history center of the
american historical association and the
wilson center co-hosted this event it's
about an hour and a half
it is my real pleasure to introduce
heather cox richardson today
someone whose work i have been reading
and admiring for some time now she is a
professor of history at boston college
and every time i think i've caught up
with what she's written she produces yet
another book
so i have to keep reading but i do so uh
with great pleasure she has written five
books on various aspects of american
history she's a 1992 graduate of harvard
university's program in the history of
american civilization
and her first four books explored civil
war reconstruction the gilded age and
the american west and they extend from
the presidencies of abraham lincoln to
that of theodore roosevelt in her
current book to make men free a history
of the republican party which was
published
late last year this was her second book
to be named as an editor's choice
selection of the new york times book
review professor richardson writes
widely for popular publication she's
very much committed to presenting
historical scholarship for audiences
well beyond the academy's walls and she
is now the editor of the and founder of
a new web magazine called we're history
she's currently at work on an
intellectual history of american
politics and a graphic treatment of the
reconstruction era heather richardson
thank you very much it is a real
pleasure to be here
and not just because i'm coming from
boston
can everybody hear me
in the back
are we okay
yes terrific
what i wanted to talk about today is not
just the republican party but why we
might care about the republican party
even if we're not necessarily into
politics
and what i'd like to argue it needs to
be turned on
now see that's why i asked you if you
could hear back there okay
are we good
you can care about this material even if
you don't care about the republican or
the democratic parties because what i
want to argue today is that the main
theme of the republican party is in fact
the main theme of american history and
it's a theme which we are grappling with
today and have been since the very
founding of america
these are our two founding documents we
have the declaration of independence in
the constitution and they're very
different documents our students tend to
put them together but they're very
different documents the declaration of
independence was a treatise explaining
to the world why america had a duty to
break off from the king of england and
the declaration of independence promises
every american man
and of course they're going to be
caveats to that equality of opportunity
that was the principle on which the
founding fathers launched the revolution
and it was a great principle on which
you could get people to rally behind
what looked initially to be a losing war
it was a great idea but it's not an idea
on which you can found a nation and what
founded the nation was the constitution
which came many years later and by the
time that the founding fathers wrote the
constitution they had a very different
set of concerns at hand and what they
were worried about then was the
stability of the new nation that they
were trying to create
the constitution rather than
guaranteeing equality of opportunity
protects property as you know and what i
would like to set up is that this
fundamental tension in america between
the idea of equality of opportunity
and protection of property
has been the driving force behind our
politics since the very beginning of the
founding of the new republic
not the magazine
what happened was that during the
revolution you know one of the reasons
that americans
complained about the rule of great
britain was that
it was against the law to move across
the appalachian mountains and one of the
first things that happens during the
revolution is that daniel boone who's
kind of a nerd do well sneaks across the
appalachians to see what's on the other
side and what he discovers is this great
land of kentucky
immediately after the revolution land
speculators in kentucky produce a
document called the present state of
kentucky which is really designed to get
people to go buy land over across the
mountains that's why we know daniel
boone by the way is because of the
present state of kentucky it has a whole
section on him and if anybody's
interested it is now on google books
easy to find online
but daniel boone comes back to virginia
and he because kentucky is to the west
of virginia and he comes back and he
tells everybody in virginia what a
phenomenal place virginia is and in the
present state of kentucky that john
felson who writes it says that kentucky
is such a rich land that you actually
have to farm for 10 years or so before
you can weaken the land enough to grow a
normal amount of crops i mean this is
this is the best possible kind of land
for this new nation to have and it's one
of the first american documents after
the nation has been founded
that talks about what the west is going
to mean what is the west well one of the
things the west is is it's a very rich
land that is going to give every man
that equality of opportunity that's
promised in the declaration of
independence
so there is a land rush immediately
after the founding of the constitution
into that new state of kentucky and it's
led by people like daniel boone
it's a much later picture of course but
it's a great picture very famous picture
of george caleb bingham uh imagining
what it was like when daniel boone who
didn't look anything at all like this
uh took people out west daniel boone
himself was as i say quite a nerd do
well his wife gave up on at one point
went back to her father
but this is important
for american culture obviously the whole
daniel boone story but also for our
political story because
this first land rush into kentucky
suggests that every man has equality of
opportunity that as long as you can get
to that new western land this new
american land you're going to be able to
rise because you know after all the land
is so strong and so good you gotta have
to farm it for 10 years before it's weak
enough that stuff actually doesn't just
jump out of the ground at you and
there's i'm not making that up by the
way and um
and there are there are animals
everywhere roaming around begging to be
killed and fish everywhere i mean this
is just this incredible land right but
the problem is that all these people who
rush into kentucky are not equal and it
becomes clear very quickly that some
people are going to do much better in
kentucky than others and one of the
people who is convinced by daniel boone
to go west into kentucky is his distant
relative a man named abraham lincoln not
our abraham lincoln but abraham
lincoln's grandfather was actually a
distant relative of of daniel boone and
the speculation is that he lived on the
road that daniel boone took when he came
back out of kentucky to find his wife
who who'd gone off to her father um and
he stopped for a night of the lincoln's
house i mean that's all anecdotal we
don't know but it's not a stretch to say
that abraham lincoln the grandfather
heard about this fabulous land in
kentucky from daniel boone in any case
he's one of the people who starts going
on this land rush to kentucky and he
gets to kentucky and he does extremely
well in kentucky he gets thousands of
acres of land uh he gets plenty of land
for farming and he and his three sons
are out in their fields one day getting
ready to prepare the sod to plant
when the people who actually
live on the land the indians who own it
decide they don't want them there and
they kill abraham lincoln
the grandfather
this is of interest to america's
political story because
kentucky is governed by virginia's land
laws and virginia's i'm sorry virginia's
laws and virginia's laws start with
primogeniture
so our abraham lincoln's
uncle mordecai the oldest son gets
everything and uncle mordecai becomes a
a breeder of racehorses he does
extremely well in kentucky he becomes a
leader in the in this in kentucky's uh
in the state of kentucky but his two
younger brothers josiah and thomas
thomas being our abraham lincoln's
father never even learned to read they
become day laborers
because they don't get anything when
their father is killed
so it becomes clear
that there's a real problem in kentucky
and the same people who wrote some of
the same people who wrote the
declaration of independence and the
constitution decide that they need to
fix the potential problems in kentucky
one is primogeniture but the other is
slave holding and their problem with
slave holding in kentucky is not that
they care about slavery one way or
another except for the fact that what it
does is it allows
a certain class of men to amass a
fortune because their amassing wealth
based on the labor of other people to
amass a fortune and then to take over
kentucky's political system
so they're concerned about that
um
in part because of what happens to men
like thomas lincoln abraham lincoln's
father and that's the thomas lincoln
after his father is killed by indians
becomes a day laborer and slowly works
his way up and he does pretty well for a
guy in these conditions
his family ends up with some household
goods he ends up with minor positions of
authority in his community but when the
slave holders start to feel that their
lands are getting that they're crowded
that their lands are getting um crowded
in kentucky they begin to
take over more and more of the land of
the poorer men like thomas lincoln and
the problem is that very few people have
deeds to their land in kentucky
and the only way you can protect your
deed
is to argue for your deed in court and
the courts are back in virginia so the
only guys who can afford to protect
their land are the guys who have money
what happens is people like thomas
lincoln get forced out of kentucky and
that's why the lincoln's leave kentucky
and they go
to indiana not to illinois that's going
to be later
indiana is a this is a really important
move for america's political system
because indiana is protected by congress
on the articles of confederation
actually
in 1787 under the northwest ordinance
when the founding fathers first
understood that they had a problem with
kentucky
and they do it reacting to kentucky and
the northwest ordinance that we tend to
think of as prohibiting slavery which is
one of the last things that ordinance
does
also the second thing it does is it
prohibits primogeniture in these lands
uh will become the five states of the
northwest in america
the reason for that is because they are
determined that they're not going to end
up with a system an oligarchical system
where a few wealthy men can take over
the government get wealthy buy up the
government buy up the court system and
pass laws that will only protect them
that will in fact leave people like
thomas lincoln out in the cold
so abraham lincoln's father moves to
indiana he does not do well in indiana
it's where
lincoln's mother dies
and
later on he moves to illinois he never
really gets his feet under him again
but
among the people who have moved into
this northwest territory there is the
idea that government should not be
dominated by a few wealthy people they
hold very strongly to the northwest
ordinance which is after all based on a
law that was written by thomas jefferson
who is the same person who wrote
or cribbed
the declaration of independence
his name is associated with both of
those laws and you see this very
strongly for example in the lincoln
douglas debates lincoln talks about it a
lot
lincoln and people like him believe that
the government should not be controlled
by a few wealthy men
and they're fairly confident that their
that this has been taken care of with
the northwest ordinance and later on in
1820 they're going to fight over the
missouri compromise which again is going
to divide the land that's that's
acquired by the united states
with the louisiana purchase of 1803 it's
going to divide that between the area
the southern area in which slavery can
be permitted and the northern area in
which it cannot be permitted and that's
the line that runs under the state of
missouri making missouri the only slave
state north of that line during the
civil war
so they're okay up through the
compromise of 18 i'm sorry up through
the missouri compromise and and there's
going to continue to be trouble in
america throughout the 1820s and the
1830s about the spread of slavery but
it's not going to be that much of a
political story until after 1848 with
the treaty of guadalupe dalgo which is
going to expand america for the entire
rest of the west you know when i started
teaching this stuff and teaching about
the missouri compromise somehow people
had always said it in such a way that i
thought the missouri compromise line ran
all the way to california and it doesn't
the missouri compromise line covered
very relatively little land compared to
the treaty of guadalupe hidalgo and the
gadsden purchase of 1854 that nobody
ever hears about but that's really
important because it sparks the wars
with geronimo that's all i get to say
about it but it's a really cool story
are you with me so far on this
because we haven't even gotten the
republican party yet
but we're getting there
and i've got plenty of time left so
but what happens is that
this treaty of guadalupe hidalgo in 1848
is going to break that concept that the
american system has been set up in such
a way that every individual can rise and
what happens is in 1854
the game changes and the game changes
with the passage of the kansas nebraska
act which is you know my favorite law in
american history you know just for
trivia there because with
the kansas nebraska act the south renegs
on the promise of the compromi of the
missouri compromise of 1820 which is not
a constitutional amendment it's only a
law so they're overriding that law and
there's lots of twists and turns to that
but in the northerners eyes this was a
sacred law the idea that in fact slavery
would not spread into the west because
if slavery could spread into the west
rich men slave owners could take over
government
it was only a question of time if they
took over the west before they took over
the entire government because once you
start taking those western states
which the party is going to do in the
1880s once you start taking those
western states you're going to shift the
balance of the electoral college and
you're going to shift the balance of
congress
both in the house of representatives
which is less important because the real
popular states are on the east coast but
in the senate if you can start taking
those western states and making them
dominated by slave owners it's only a
question of time until slave owners with
their oligarchical system is going to
control the government
have i sold you on that so far
because it's a very different look at
the mid 19th century that what we're
really fighting about is government who
has a say in american government and
what does the american government do
does it promote equality of opportunity
or does it protect property and what
you're going to see in the middle of the
19th century is republicans like
abraham lincoln
standing very strongly on the idea and
this by the way is the brady portrait um
the first brady portrait uh taken when
he came to new york to give the speech
at cooper union in 59
you get people like abraham lincoln
standing on the declaration of
independence and the idea that the
government has
a duty
to make sure that every man has an equal
opportunity to rise and that the
government does not get taken over by
the very wealthy
on the other hand you have powerful
slave owners standing on the
constitution and saying that the
government has a duty to protect
property and that's their argument for
spreading slavery into the west is that
because slaves slaves are property
they must be protected under the
constitution so their right to carry
slaves into the west is protected by the
american constitution it's a fundamental
contradiction between the declaration of
independence which is not foundational
to our system of laws it's only our
aspiration
and the constitution which is our
fundamental law and this is the fight
that we're going to play out during the
civil war
so what happens is the republican party
forms and starts to form in 1854. the
rumor is that it starts in ripon
wisconsin that's a publicity scheme by
ripon wisconsin in fact it starts in a
number of places but there's there's
movements against the kansas nebraska
act all over the north but the most
interesting piece of that story is
actually here in washington
because there were three brothers who
represented three different states in
congress and they came together at a
boarding house here in washington um
the morning after the passage of kansas
nebraska act on may 9 1854 and they came
together and they came together with
their friends
regardless of what party they were from
about 30 of them met in the rooms of
edward dickinson from massachusetts uh
here in washington and he's this
sort of a trivia point here too he's
interesting because his daughter is
emily dickinson who is not yet a recluse
she visits her father in washington
she's not there during this time but
uh they pick that room the two men from
massachusetts because that boarding
house has the best food in washington
not kidding
they all go into this meeting from all
these different parties
and they come out saying we must
organize a new party
to stand against the slave power that is
taking over our government and turning
it into an oligarchy and they they just
suggest that they should take the name
republican after jefferson and the
declaration of independence and that's
one of the i think i think the most
important foundational moments of the
republican party takes a long time to
get people to sign up in 1854 and then
in 1855 people get elected on what are
called anti-nebraska tickets they're
just people who don't like the law they
don't yet have a common theme but it's
that 1854 meeting here in washington
that really gets the ball rolling
because all 30 of these guys then go
home for their summer recess
and whip up party in their states and
they're all as i say connected both by
blood and by friendship
that party
is organized against the kansas nebraska
act but it's really abraham lincoln's
party in the sense that it's abraham
lincoln who articulates a
forward-looking vision for the party in
a way that nobody who simply stands
against the kansas nebraska act can
he thinks a lot he doesn't actually join
the party in 54 but he's he is so
incensed by the passage of the kansas
nebraska act he sits up all night
keeping joshua's speed awake
and rails about how terrible this is how
this is
the end of american government this is
something we must all stand against and
he flirts with the party for a while but
mostly he thinks
and then in
1854 i'm sorry 1858
a southern
senator james henry hammond gives a
speech in which he are taking on the
floor of congress in which he
articulates
the idea that in fact the american
government is designed to protect the
very wealthy it's called the cotton is
king speech but it ought to be called
the mud sill speech because in that
speech he argues that a good society
operates in such a way that the vast
majority of people
are on the bottom they are literally the
mud sills and a mud sill is a piece of
wood that's driven into the ground to
support a building
in the in the dirt you know the days
before concrete mcadam and things
they are the mud sills they are dumb
they're happy just to work they don't
want much they like to sing and dance
uh they need to be told how to behave
and on that mud sill rests the cream of
society they are the makers they're the
doers they're the people who understand
how society should work they're educated
they have connections in foreign
countries
they are the ones who are moving society
forward and hammond says you know
i can prove it to you we're the
wealthiest people in the country we're
some of the wealthiest people in the
world we have rembrandts hanging on our
walls we're educated our sons are
educated
we are what america stands for we are
the ones who are going to move society
forward
on this system of the world in which all
the poor people work for us and we
direct their labor it's hard work
directing their labor but we're willing
to sacrifice ourselves to it
it's an astonishing speech
that too is available on google books if
you search james henry hammond has if
there's a
a book of his speeches on google books
you can't get it in full text anywhere
else except through the congressional
record
it's in full text in that speech
well in response to that abraham lincoln
gives a really powerful speech to the
wisconsin agricultural fair in 1859 and
in that he says no
that is not what america stands for
and he says you know
people he doesn't he doesn't actually
articulate this in this speech but he
will in other places he's a mud cell
he
he grew up in in indiana in a home that
that literally only had three walls it
was open on the fourth side that's where
they put the fire because they didn't
have the time to make the fourth wall
he grew up working in the fields he
didn't get an education was it true that
he was in fact somebody who should be
directed by people like james henry
hammond who had a very nasty way with
his slaves male and female as well as
his nieces
and who was really
willing to stand on the floor of
congress and say
i didn't actually read this bill
i don't actually know what's in it but i
know i should vote with my friends
you know which he says in the cotton is
king speech i paraphrase by the way
is it true that he should
be below that sort of a man no
he says america is about free labor it's
about the idea that any man
has the right to the fruits of his own
labor and everybody should have equality
of opportunity that's what america is
about and that is america's definition
of free labor
well as you know in 1860 he is nominated
to become president and he wins the 1860
election
when that happens the republicans do
very well in that election but they
probably couldn't have done a lot in
congress because they did not have a uh
control
the democrats were still extraordinarily
powerful they still had a lot of
committees they still had uh a
a powerful minority in the north they
they would have been able to stop the
republicans from doing much that they
wanted to do but of course the democrats
left
they picked up their bags and they took
their marbles and they went home
and when they did that they forced the
republican party to redefine the
american government in a way that has
shaped our our modern world today
the republicans when they were elected
were brand new
they were they weren't a decade old yet
all they knew is they didn't like the
slave power that's all they knew and
that they suddenly were in power
well the first thing that they have to
do
of course is to fight the war and they
have no money to do it
so over the course of the next four
years they're going to
field an army that eventually
incorporates more than a million men and
a navy
and uh supply all those men
they're going to fight this war in both
the south and the west
they're going to manage to keep the
union intact this is no small feat
but they're going to do more than that i
mean i i love this image because the
republicans very deliberately continued
construction on the capitol building
during the war even though they had
no money because they recognized that
they were building a nation
and the construction of the capital goes
on during the war it never stops until
by the time of the troop review in 65
the the capital dome is done
are almost done
in addition to fighting the war it's
just again no small feat in addition to
fighting the war
the republicans during the civil war
change the american government and they
do it in such a way that the government
begins to try and encourage
every man to be able to rise
in 1862 they passed the homestead act to
put men onto farms with the idea that
farming is the primary
position in the economy that if you can
get people onto the ground and they can
start producing crops they're going to
produce a surplus that's going to
enable them to accumulate capital which
the republicans actually call
pre-exerted labor and they're going to
be able to recycle that back into
society by hiring farm hands who will
then be able to buy their own property
and this cycle as one
newspaper reporter says should continue
until every
pauper is equipped with a coach in four
so in 1862 they
passed the homestead act they also
passed the land grant college act which
is the foundation of all of our state
universities except the university of
north carolina
i've heard that one an awful lot it was
actually established before the land
grant college act
with the idea that people would use
their
labor more efficiently if they could be
educated about how to do it
they also passed the department of
agriculture
again with the idea that the more people
know about good seeds and good farming
practices the better they will be able
to produce and the faster they'll be
able to rise
not just that though the
republicans during the civil war
encourage immigrants to come to america
they actually find ways to find
immigrate immigrants to come to america
because they're desperate to get people
into the fields so they will produce
more crops
and they pass the union pacific railroad
act in 1862 and then revised it in 1864
in order to get people both onto the
fields in the west but also into the
mines both in uh
california of course but also nevada
which opens up in 62
and in montana which opens up
dramatically in 64 with a major gold
strike they want to get people out there
and they want to get them producing
because
they need
the money
that those people are going to produce
they need that production they also need
the taxes that they are going to impose
on those people to pay for the war
because that's the piece that people
tend to forget about the republicans
during the civil war is they invent our
first national taxation we do not have
taxation in america at the national
level until 1861.
uh the the previous wars are paid for
differently if anybody cares i can tell
you how
they not only create what are called
manufacturing taxes which for our
purposes you can consider sales taxes
they're not
but close enough
they also impose an income tax and they
create what is going to become the irs
because
for a number of reasons but because they
have to pay for the war
they're desperate to pay for money to
get money to pay for the war and because
they believe that paying taxes into the
union is going to give everybody a stake
in what happens to that
union government
they also do it because at the beginning
of the war bankers are really not nearly
as enthusiastic about the war as the
treasury needs them to be and it's a
fascinating story i'm happy to go into
but again for our purposes beginning in
1860 begins to turn away from bankers
and put the foundation of the american
financial system onto individuals and
onto taxation rather than on to the
previous bank loans that had managed to
keep the country afloat before the civil
war
so during the war
the republicans throw their weight
behind the idea that every man should
have an opportunity to rise and that the
government has a duty to make that
happen and must make that happen
and it's all great and we can all go
home now right
but what happens in 1865 march of 1865
is it's clear that people in the south
are starving to death white people as
well as black people are literally
starving to death the south is
devastated sometimes americans forget
just how bad off the south is the end of
the war people are starving
people with ptsd are trying to get home
there are gangs roving around the south
uh if you try if you even bother to hire
somebody to kill someone in texas it
costs about three dollars easier to pick
them off yourself
uh when the confederacy collapses
it takes with it all the police forces
the south is
devastated and the congress is very
aware of that not only because they care
about the well-being of of the
african-americans who fought for the war
but also because these are their cousins
and family members who are starving down
there so in march of 1865 congress
creates
the bureau of refugees freedmen and
abandoned lands that's its official name
it becomes known as the freedmen's
bureau
the freedmen's bureau is designed it's
put in the war department with us to
signal that it is only going to last for
a year after the wars end
but of course
as you know
congress adjourns for the summer
an hour before abraham lincoln takes a
second inaugural
and they all go home because it's been a
long war right it's not over yet by the
way it's not going to end until actually
stan watty puts down his he's this the
the last confederate general to put down
his arms in the summer 65 he's a he's a
cherokee
they go home
and in mid
april abraham lincoln is assassinated
and that puts andrew johnson a former
democrat in charge of reconstructing the
union
until december of 1865 he is solely in
charge of that now he could have
recalled congress
as everybody expected him to but he
didn't want any part of it because he's
an old democrat who adheres to the idea
that what congr what the government is
supposed to do is to protect property
and he is terrified of the republicans
because they are so enormously popular
if they bring their system of homesteads
and
education to the south the democrats
will never get elected again and there
goes his political career
andrew johnson attacks the republican
idea
of using the government to promote
equality of opportunity by
insisting and this is crucially
important in his two vetoes of six 1866
that what the republicans are really
doing
is not creating equality of opportunity
for all men
we're not going to talk about women at
all today although i can if you want to
um
what they are tr what they are really
doing
is redistributing wealth
to keep themselves in power
exactly what james henry hammond said
what happened when he said in 1858 in
the in the mud cell speech the cotton is
king speech that you couldn't let poor
people have access to the government
because if they did they would vote to
redistribute wealth they would want more
of the stuff they were producing and
that's precisely what andrew johnson
says is happening with the freedmen's
bureau that it's an attempt of
republicans
to redistribute tax dollars
to african-americans
that should sound fairly familiar
and let me tell you how it plays out
this is the first crack in the idea the
republican idea that the government
should be used to promote equality of
opportunity
but it's not the last necessity that one
of the one of the big things that
happens here is in the realm of women's
history but there isn't enough time
right now to go into that
by 18
southern democrats have been complaining
bitterly about the
13th amendment the 14th amendment the
15th amendment the military
reconstruction act uh the freedmen's
bureau they keep saying that what's
going on here is the republicans are
using the government to
funnel white tax dollars to lazy african
americans
and in 18 and and northerners have paid
no attention to this uh because they say
you're all a bunch of racist pigs they
don't actually say that but actually
they do
but in 1871 in south carolina there is a
movement that reorganizes opposition to
the republicans under a taxpayer's
protest and this is a very famous image
from the south carolina south carolina
taxpayers protest in which
south white south carolinians who are
famous for their racist opposition to
african-americans across the board but
certainly their political voices
organized to say that what's really
going on in south carolina is that black
people who can now vote
are putting in place legislators who are
stealing tax dollars from white people
to
redistribute them to black people and
they're doing it with things like roads
and hospitals and schools and all of
those things that are being voted for by
african americans are in fact largely
being paid for by white south
carolinians who are the only ones who
have any property they also change the
basis of taxes and take it off the uh
the professionals and put it on to land
but this obviously makes it
into popular culture there's a very
famous image but most people don't know
what it says and i i actually can't read
with these glasses on but it says i
believe you are aping the lowest whites
if you cannot behave better you need to
take back seats if you cannot behave
yourselves you need to take you need to
sit in the back
and if you look at that image you will
see that although it's famous for its
caricatures of african americans in fact
there are also poor whites being
caricatured in that picture
so how does this play out and why does
the north start to listen well by 1871
northerners have their own problems
northerners are very worried about the
rise of labor and the rise of labor
industries um the rise of the labor
movement that is organizing and
beginning to suggest that it in fact is
not happy with the way the civil the the
legislation of the civil war played out
that is
workers real wages took a hit during the
war and they're not making up the ground
they need to after the war so in 1866
they organized the national labor union
they organized the knights of labor in
1869 and then in 1871
in the wake of the franco-prussian war
the paris commune
uh the communion arts in paris take over
paris from march through may of 1871.
now what actually happens in paris is
beyond me i don't know anything about
france what happens in america though is
americans look at this and they believe
they see a world where laborers have
taken over the government they are
redistributing wealth and they are
killing the upper classes they're
bombing buildings they burn the
twigleries women are
taking to the streets and throwing
bottles full of this stuff called
petroleum and setting it on fire and
blowing up buildings with it i mean it
doesn't get
worse than that that's 1871 in march
through may and then of course in 1871
in october october 8th
chicago burns
and the rumors in the papers incorrectly
are that this is laborers trying to
destroy paris i'm sorry trying to
destroy chicago the same way they
destroyed paris that in fact anarchy
socialism which is a different term at
the time and
communism coming from the communards not
from the bolsheviks who aren't even born
yet
is going to destroy america
well how does this play out in the north
i'm sorry i thought i cut some words out
of that in in october of 1871
the same year the new york times breaks
the story that william marcy tweed of
the tweed ring
uh the of tammany hall who's a democrat
is doing the exact same thing in a in a
new york city
he is using
tax dollars collected from wealthy
people in this case republicans and
using them to fund government contracts
that are keeping immigrants and
democrats
in jobs so they will vote the democratic
ticket he is corrupting
the american government
and that's what the word corruption
originally meant in the 19th century not
payoffs although there were those two
but the corruption of the body politic
by inserting in it uh a self
uh
the
self-interest
a personal self-interest that was bad
for the government at large
well why does this matter
uh all this matters it matters because
andrew johnson finally goes away
and u.s grant is elected in 1868
but u.s grant is brilliant for the
record brilliant writer among other
things and he did something else um oh
he won the civil war
um but charles sumner believed he should
be in charge of the republican party and
he hated grant made fun of him they used
to sit in the cloak room and poke fun at
this backwoods bumpkin
charles sumner wants to
take over the party from grant
and he uses the language of
andrew johnson the southern democrats
the people who are afraid of tammany
hall to attack grants southern
governments
he says that grant
is corrupt
he is he is only supporting
african-american rights because he is
trying to keep himself in power with
black votes and he's going to be using
tax dollars to provide goodies for those
black people so they will continue to
vote for him
charles sumner and his friend here carl
schertz who's below him become
instrumental in developing this idea
that the republican government that
helps african americans is corrupt and i
put this other little picture here
because i love the juxtaposition of
shirts and this other little guy who's
somewhat important in american history
you can tell he's fond of shirts does
anyone know who that is
you might have heard of him that's
joseph pulitzer which is how all of this
stuff hits the newspapers and gets
absorbed as dramatically as it does well
as grant is forced away from those men
he needs to make up the difference
somewhere and he gets pushed toward with
the man who was known as the handsomest
man in the 19th century go figure
roscoe conkling
who is below him
and who runs the state of new york
uh interesting man conkling and i can
tell you stories
um
but congling is very important because
conkling runs new york and everybody
forgets how important new york is new
york has uh by the end by the later on
the 70s it's going to have 36 electoral
votes but we'll call it 35 for now
electoral votes look how few everybody
else has compared to new york if you're
going to hold the white house you must
hold new york if you're going to hold
new york you must hold wall street what
happens is after 1872 actually in the
1872 election
grant as the leader of the republican
party swings to wall street
by the 1880s the republican party is
firmly in the hands of property people
men
in this era uh this this says the trust
giants point of view by the 1880s even
staunchly republican
newspapers are complaining that the
trusts wealthy men own congress the
senators are actually named according to
which trusts that they represent
so we've got rockefeller playing with
the white house as a toy
and the capitol building in
uh in in
shooting oil there it's interesting
image isn't it
by the 1880s the republican party
believes that it alone stands between
america and the apocalypse until we have
the election the illegal election by the
way benjamin harrison lost the
popular vote by a hundred thousand votes
he's one of the three presidents in
american history who loses the popular
vote and yet takes the white house
there's a corrupt bargain that goes on
in
the electoral college over him
and he says the difference between the
parties the republicans and the
democrats is the difference between the
light and darkness day and night it's
good or bad and the businessmen are good
by 1892 we have this very famous image
of
the single man in front of carnegie's
homestead plant
this is set up image by the way it's not
it's just a snapshot but it shows how
much the balance is
has been thrown off between equality of
opportunity and property and that's what
this image was set up to show
and it hits a lot of republicans that
things have gone too far
by the turn of the century we have the
rise of the progressive republicans who
take a look at what's happened in the
1880s and the 1890s and say this is not
our government
in this period in what becomes known as
the progressive era under teddy
roosevelt um people like fighting bob
lafollette and roosevelt switched the
meaning of the word liberal liberal had
previously called for a small government
that protected rights of individuals and
now it called for a strong government
that would reign in
the rockefellers and the carnegie's to
enable individuals to rise so this
meaning of liberal switches in this era
but that doesn't relieve the wealthy
people who are standing on the
constitution until we have this
quotation that i've never been able to
resist
um
about how everybody in america is a
communist except him basically including
a man that goes on to be
a supporter of adolf hitler so the bar
is really really low here
for communism
by the 1920s these people
have taken back over the american
government and in the 1920s the election
of 1920 the landslide election of 1920
is a very important one in american
history because it's the one where the
idea of
government
promoting equality of opportunity loses
uh the people who still believe that go
into the arts a lot and they go into the
progressive party which is in tatters at
that point but basically for the 1920s
people who believe that the government
should be promoting big business hold
all the cards and we know where that
goes in october
of
uh 1929 but we have quotations from that
era like this that injecting government
into the economy will poison the country
and that the idea that the government
should do things to promote equality of
opportunity was the same philosophy that
poisoned the fumes of the witch's
cauldron which boiled in russia
democrats are the party of the mob
uh sounds quite a bit like james henry
hammond
well we know where that goes
we get the depression
and from that the cycle starts again
we get the rise of another guy who did a
few useful things in the world and it
always infuriates me that people think
of him as elmer fudd because uh
dwight eisenhower is one of the
brightest men that has ever sat in the
white house uh he and i i've read all of
his stuff he really is is brilliant
but he saw the world in the same way
that lincoln and roosevelt did that the
government's job was to promote equality
of opportunity and that the way to do
that was to make it easier for everybody
to have access to equal opportunity
he does things of course like
back the the highway act of 18 1956
which is the largest public works
program in american history
and he is determined to stop the
government from pouring money into
useless army armament city things are
useless and instead to develop the
infrastructure of the economy to make it
easier for people to rise not only in
america but also across the world it
doesn't always work out as we know
uh but his driving principle is that it
has to be possible for every man
everywhere to rise because if it's not
those people who are economically and
religiously dispossessed are prime
fodder for dictators who with the advent
of the nuclear weapon can literally
destroy the world which it seems to me
is prescient
eisenhower again is
opposed from within his own party by
people who insist that the government
doing anything other than protecting
property
are
communists this is a young william f
buckley jr mccarthy of course and barry
goldwater who carries that idea on and
nobody pays a great deal of attention to
them until eisenhower sends the troops
into little rock in 1957 and when he
does that sending the troops to the
south for the first time since
reconstruction
we have once again the language emerging
that
american the american government is
using white tax dollars to help lazy
african americans
that theme is going to continue through
the 1960s when
um
the kennedy brothers
integrate or
use the troops to integrate the
university of mississippi we have the
castro brothers moving into the white
house
1970 we have the rise in 68 1970 of the
southern strategy in the republican
party people think that stone mountain
is from the reconstruction era in fact
it's dedicated in may of 18 1970. spiro
agnew dedicates that nixon was supposed
to be there but he had a little bit of
trouble with something called kent state
that weekend
here's another image from that era
this is taken in 72 it's from a private
collection it has not been published it
says this is clan country love it or
leave it fight communism
and integration
this theme of african american activism
and
activist government helping them being
communism has carried to the present
we have reagan's welfare queen
and we have the rising stratification of
wealth the same way we did in the 1890s
and the 1920s to the very top of the 1
in american history you guys have all
seen these numbers so i won't belabor
them
we know where that went in 2008
hard to find this image now but i like
it
but these themes have continued
also images from the present obama is
socialism
one of the things got me writing this
book i thought he's a communist him and
castro there's like two left in the
world who knew
socialism is evil
obama's plan is white slavery
free market not freeloaders just say no
to socialism
taxed enough already yes we can take all
your money
as you know uh our tax burden has not
actually gone down since the reagan
years just who pays it has changed
and to to wrap up i i
actually was a few minutes late because
i was sitting across the street um
typing in something i just just came
across my twitter feed in response to a
piece of mine that came out yesterday
and this is the twitter description from
a man who took exception to the idea uh
that there was a theme going on in
republican history and this is how he
describes himself and to me it looked
very much
like
william henry i'm sorry benjamin
harrison
laugh out loud and your expectation in
pc assumption that to agree is to
disagree is to default hell no
one of us is right and one of us is
wrong
period
and he's a big supporter of the right
so what i'd like to suggest is that the
true republican party from its
beginnings was one that believed in the
declaration of independence and the idea
that every man should have an
opportunity and woman
by now i should have an equal
opportunity uh to rise in american
society but that adherence to the
declaration of independence is not the
only theme that runs through american
life the other theme is of course an
adherence to the protection of property
that is guaranteed by the constitution
and
we still in america have not worked out
that tension between the declaration of
independence's protection of uh the the
right of every man to equality of
opportunity and the constitution's
protection of property and we swing
between those two polls
back and forth in part
now because of the theme set up by the
republican party in its early years
that
an activist government that enables
people to rise is in fact because of the
peculiarities of reconstruction seen as
socialism
good enough
[Applause]
thank you so much heather that was that
was great
i'm sure there are lots of questions and
comments if as always you could please
wait for the
microphone and state your name
and affiliation if you like
we'll start over here
and james banner
uh professor
richardson what a pleasure um
it's nice to you
um
you've given aw
you've offered a wonderful
narrative of american history
seems to me overlaid with the history of
the republican party
um
one half is missing
it's known as the other party couldn't
you
tell the same story
in democratic hues
finding within the democratic party
on the same
bifurcation of impulses
for the very reason that you
assert namely
it's the
the binary tension within american
history
and does it really affect
a single party
only no i don't think it does but
you know people always say to me why
don't you talk about the democrats and i
don't talk about the democrats because i
study the republicans
but that being but no no you don't have
to let me off the hook because i've had
to think about this and especially as
people have said why don't you write a
history of the democratic party
and i said no so many times that i
started to think maybe i should i think
the democrats have a very different
trajectory than the republicans do and
they're there it's a very interesting
trajectory they're much older of course
and they rose at a very different time
and they rose with a different set of
imperatives so my impression of the two
parties is that they are not yin and
yang they are they occasionally brush up
against each other especially at
critical times but they have different
languages going on and different
imperatives in them and one of the
places that they are that i couldn't go
into at all here and i really didn't go
into in the book because there wasn't
space for it the original manuscript was
over a thousand pages long
um
is that the democrats since the civil
war have had a terrible problem and
that's that they have been very
successfully painted as
anti-american
and that
gets its roots of course from the civil
war when they were anti-american you
know they tried to destroy the country
and that comes up again i mean it comes
up again and again and again so in 1870
1878 the the house and the senate go
democratic and and the democrats move
their people into congress and they say
man we should never seceded we're just
going to run things from congress this
is great
and and literally they say that and
there's poems all over the country and
and drawings of like man we just lost
the civil war how did this happen
and um and so that's the 1880s cleveland
is portrayed as a confederate woodrow
wilson whose father was a confederate
um that goes on right through jimmy
carter southerner you know and that
theme of always having to prove that
they are not anti-american is something
that the republicans they got in their
back pocket we won the civil war
and that's something the democrats have
never been able to overcome so i think
the trajectory from the fact they're
earlier they're they're even before
jackson but they're really formed around
jackson and around the whole the
impulses of the 1830s
that's an issue
and then of course with the civil war
and the you guys are the enemy thing um
those things have been hugely important
and then foreign affairs i mean they're
really they've really been fighting the
foreign affairs thing in a way the
republicans have been a very different
wavelength in the entire 20th century um
but i don't think i'm going to write a
book on it
okay
all the way in the back
stephen sure one correction and on two
brief comments you confused harrison's
election with the one of 1876 that was
hayes that was no no no hayes two hayes
lost by 250 000 votes and harrison by a
hundred thousand believe me i know
that's okay they're both law one they
both won a popular majority uh they both
won the presidency despite winning a
popular majority
uh despite winning not winning a pop
fight but they won the electoral in the
electoral college yes but hayes that was
essentially given up by democrats in a
bargain to end um troops in the south
whereas no that's not right actually the
um believe me i get really bored so i
look up stuff that nobody else does they
don't take the troops out of the south
there are no troops in the south over
that there are very very few that's all
played out through congress what happens
in 77
and there isn't a bargain um and that's
it's actually way more than you want to
know but if you do want to know i got
great stories about it um
that's
they got to take troops out of the the
very few troops that america even has
have to go fight the lakota and they
have to fight the um the great railroad
strike of 77. that's why the few troops
that are still in the south i mean
there's like one guy in a tent i'm
exaggerating
but there are very few people left so
that bar whole bargain thing that's just
okay i meant to this is as a peripheral
thing
pisses me off because it's in all the
books and it's wrong if you compare the
elect the electoral maps of 1904 and 19
out and 2008 it's virtu virtual absolute
flip that parties the two parties have
traded constituencies and the democrats
complain about how difficult it is to
get white working men to vote for them
these days and the other uh my other
comment is that there were all the
republicans always had an elitist
uh
group the union league was not exactly
all that in favor of equal opportunity
yet was one of lincoln's greatest
supporters and there were always
businessmen who recognized that a
maldistribution of income ultimately
threatened property and saw the best way
of protecting their own property by uh
allowing the prosperity of the many like
henry ford for all his faults wanted his
workers to be able to afford his cars
so there was always this constituency of
businessmen largely men of course who
wanted a more equal distribution of
income as a best way of protecting their
own property right and that's certainly
teddy roosevelt i mean that's that's
what he's up to and that's what fdr is
up to too for that matter um i think i
think the difference between 1904 and
2008 if that's the election you said or
2006 i think there's there's a major
realignment that goes on in the 1960s
and that that makes a big difference but
yeah you're absolutely right and and you
know not all rich men were republicans
either vanderbilt isn't he's a democrat
gentleman next to
yeah
uh will amitruda
responding to your remarks about andrew
johnson
and your picture of him as as uh
defending uh the the entrance of the
wealthy
uh while i'm certainly no andrew johnson
expert my understanding was he
uh
well first of course he was the only
southern senator who who
who stayed in the senate he was from
east tennessee which was the loyal part
of tennessee
and from what i've read about him he
he had a visceral dislike of of the
wealthy landowners and slave owners uh i
mean granted he was a rabid racist
uh
so
you know are both of these pictures
right
i'm sorry if i if i misspoke and said
that he was in favor of the wealthy
you're absolutely right in his
proclamation uh of amnesty the the one
group he excludes off the the top or
anybody is worth more than twenty
thousand dollars
but what andrew johnson's interested in
is the democratic party and the
democratic party's base is wealthy
southerners and but not only i mean he's
on the side of of the the common white
man is who he's on the side of and he
but he he
in order to re resuscitate the
democratic party he's got to resuscitate
the world pretty much the way it looks
in 1860 and that's what he sets out to
do in the summer of 65.
fairly successfully really it's just
that congress refuses to accept what
he's done and they throw out the black
codes and they throw out the new state
constitutions that have been organized
under his aegis
then so no he's he's not
he does like them to court him now
you know he loves to have the the rich
guys coming and begging for pardons and
when they he won't give them pardons he
you know lets their daughters have
pardons as it were
um
so i don't really see that there's
uh i mean there might be a personal
dislike on his part but i don't think
there's a
you know politics makes strange
bedfellows and that's a place where
they're definitely in bed together
you you make him sound a lot like
pitchfork ben tillman
of south carolina
oh well no i mean tillman's got other
stuff going on but tillman's much later
tillman's much later you know tillman's
really doing his thing in the 90s and
johnson's you know johnson of
uh politician before the war i mean
there's a there's a couple of
generations going on there and the
country changes a lot
yeah
aaron jones from here at the wilson
center appreciate your your presentation
uh
one thing that struck me as you were
talking about uh eisenhower and then
kind of segueing up to today
uh it seems like since eisenhower's day
even up until now there's been
a fracture in the republican party it's
obviously what we see
mostly right now with the tea party but
the same thing was going on in the 50s
with the john birch society and
william f buckley was instrumental in
getting rid of getting the john birch
society ostracized i was wondering if
you could sort of speak to that i think
that the republicans have kind of been
just in the last week they've been shown
as being the ones holding everything up
but really was 50 republicans you had
almost 200 other republicans
who said yes to dhs funding but yet
they're sort of being
all painted with the same broad brush i
was wondering if you could kind of speak
to where we are right now with the
republican party and
whether or not this tension that's
within the republican party has anything
to do with going back to lincoln and
trying to get back to those first
principles
that's actually a really interesting
question because the whole reason any of
this stuff matters is because the part i
mean well historians think it matters
because we're we think it's cool but um
but because of what's going to happen in
the country now i mean why does this
matter in our lives and the republican
party is in dire straits mind you so is
a democratic party it's a very exciting
time to be a political historian
and i'm so pleased they did this for me
the republican party is indeed terribly
split
and it has been split since the 1950s
and it split dramatically after uh
little rock in 57
and for a number of way complicated
reasons that i actually do deal with in
the book
the the
those people
who believed in
okay there's a seminal book that's
written in 1951 by william f buckley jr
in which he it's called god man at yale
um does anybody know it it's it's a
everybody should know that book because
it's it's a bad book i mean he needed an
editor really badly but it's it's a
really interesting book because that
book says
that
there are two commandments in political
life in american political life and they
are christianity
and it's called the the uh
superstition of academic freedom is a
subtitle and that there are that the
idea of academic freedom that everybody
should be able to think and argue and
work together toward uh choosing between
different arguments and moving toward a
solution that's good for society is
wrong because people have chosen the new
deal and later on he's going to be upset
about the fact they've chosen
eisenhower's new way that's when he gets
really angry is in 1955 with the
national the establishment of the
national review
and in that book he argues that in fact
american government or any government
but he's concerned with america
must accept as a fundamental prison his
two fundamental principles christianity
and what he calls free market capitalism
that is that the government must not get
involved in any kind of business
regulation those things are not
negotiable
they are they are like the ten
commandments he talks about the ten
commandments those are
not
negotiable
now the other wing of the party which
became the rockefeller wing which is the
eisenhower wing believed that
there were fundamental principles that
the government must uphold to create
equality in society
and they were willing to to negotiate
with democrats about what worked and
what didn't eisenhower basically liked
the new deal enough but he was going to
take the rough edges off and he was
going to make it run a lot more smoothly
than the democrats did to people on the
other side on the buckley side
originally which went straight to
becoming the mccarthy side and straight
to goldwater straight to reagan and
straight from reagan to george w bush
not hw bush i mean there's a straight
lineage
of terms of who was supporting whom in
different contests and what speeches
were being given
that wing of the party cannot compromise
you cannot compromise
principles
that's not negotiable
um there's a right and there's a wrong
democrats are the mob like
harrison said
the other part of the party
is willing to give and take they have a
set of principles but they understand
that that there's
wheeling and dealing to go on and that
there are different kinds of ideas that
are
have to be on the table to move the
country forward those two things are
incompatible and that intransigent wing
of the party has gotten to be much too
powerful but interestingly enough
i think it's hanging itself
in terms of if you watch
political discussions which i do
way too closely
i mean hours every day i'm reading chat
rooms and twitter and everything to see
which way the wind is blowing
it's very different now than it was even
five years ago that that wing has become
so far out there there is a real move
afoot to bring back
the
progressive republican party of a nelson
rockefeller or of an eisenhower or of a
teddy roosevelt and
i actually every other day think that
that's going to happen
um
and we'll see but if i were putting my
money on the party right now i would put
it on that wing and not the other wing
all right kent
thank you for a terrific presentation
and the wonderful illustrations that
went with it i'm kent hughes here at the
wilson center
on the freeloading question i wonder if
in fact work hasn't become really part
of america's civic culture
so you see on the republican side a
different line that went from milton
friedman and his negative income tax
to nixon's attempt to put that into
legislative form to senator roth
republican from delaware who was a
strong advocate and with some success
the earned income tax credit
and the it's the earned part and as a
result you have an enormous amount of
redistribution via the tax code but it's
not controversial at all because
it's linked to work
that's partly rhetorical though i mean
nixon was so good especially um uh
under when buchanan was writing for him
um
was so good about creating straw men you
know they say we should take handouts
they say we should do this but you know
we should sit around and have the
government hand us things but we're hard
working americans and he managed to put
that rhetorical
attachment into the republican party
that we're the ones who work and the
democrats are the lazy ones but the
other part of the tax code that nobody
ever talks about is um tax expenditures
and that's something that almost no
americans even understand is out there
but it is what do they call it the
the uh
drawing a blank on it it's essentially
the the middle class welfare state
and the fact that you can
call that tax relief
sells it and you don't have to present
any kind of bills about it and it has
decimated the tax code and and again if
people understood taxes and what was
really going on they'd be horrified but
it's very complicated stuff there's a
young guy writing now had a good piece
in al jazeera within a week
his name sean mccall way
something
that was very useful wasn't it then
um
in which he talks about this because a
very important study on tech there's a
very important study on tax expenditures
and he's the only person i've ever seen
mention it in popular print um
but anyway i think you're absolutely
right the tax code and the way it's it's
portrayed as the tax breaks to the
hard-working americans versus the
welfare payments to the lazy ones
is central both in language and in the
way our economy goes
let me play contrarian here uh and push
you on a couple what yes you're going to
play contrarian so first i put on my
contrarian hat for the right uh and with
that hat on i will say you're presenting
kind of a straw man of the republican
party
you may have a definition of what
economic opportunity is but we believe
in our heart of hearts that what we are
doing today is promoting economic
opportunity it's just not your
definition of it and besides pointing to
reconstruction and the freeloader
problem and those graphics that you put
up don't we remember that there was in
fact considerable corruption during the
reconstruction era uh convict lease
system uh you know lines the pockets of
all sorts of people uh on the backs of
black people um
railroads uh there's a lot of money
passing hands here um so raising the
question about taxes is not illegitimate
then perhaps it's not illegitimate now
second hat put on the contrarian hat of
the left why are you being so mean to
the republican party when the democrats
um
seem virtually indistinguishable this is
the you know the occupy wall street uh
version of the story
and the democrats stand no more for
economic opportunity today than the
republicans who gutted glass-steagall it
was democrats it was the clinton
administration they they
uh uh helped contribute to the economic
crisis that did a considerable amount to
decimate uh the very people that that
you want to help so why single out the
republicans when neither political party
actually is advancing economic
opportunity the democrats like the
republicans are the party of the wealthy
okay i may not get every piece of this
so stop me
um they're all very good questions and
um i i would start by saying you did not
define what you meant by the republican
party currently promoting equality of
opportunity and i'm going to ask if that
is the idea that
it's an entrepreneurial society the way
things are now is that correct and they
might say that well do you want to
define it at all because otherwise i'm
kind up in the air
it's all rhetoric anyway on one level no
no see what's cool about this all the
stuff we do
is that we're hashing out ideas and
there are ideas that matter
so is it true that the republican party
right now promotes equality of
opportunity now people have said that to
me
and i have a hard time with that um if
you look at
who can get educations
how many jobs you have to work to
survive
where you put your kids in daycare and
how much it costs it really the actual
terms of living make it very difficult
for people who are not born into money
to advance to rise up and the statistics
bear that out
we're also looking in again this is this
is different question but that's a
problem you know our the national debt
is i believe that the national debt
not not that a national that is a
problem but a national debt that and the
state debts that are not being paid in
kansas and wisconsin and now arizona
those are a problem yeah those are it
seems to be a problem and there's a
problem that has to be dealt with and um
but then to go back to
to the republican party actually helping
people right now what i hear more often
is actually not that
um because what you hear is these people
deserve what they got
to which my answer is
i actually believe in a society that is
motivated by a profit motive that um you
know the because what you usually hear
with when people complain about my work
is well you just want collectivism and
in fact i don't want collectivism i
don't think it works very well i think
america has this genius of being able to
promote
innovation dramatic innovation and still
have a safety net and a lot of countries
don't seem to manage to hit that sweet
spot and right now we don't we haven't
either
but
right now
with wealth continuing to stratify
continuing to move upward making it very
very difficult for anybody to move up
there you move up you also have the
problem of a lot of people who are
making a lot of money and not paying
their own weight in society not pulling
their own weight in society and there's
many different reasons that i think
that's a bad idea
i don't hear that so much as i hear what
the republicans really stand for is
liberty
that this is a piece that's missing it's
liberty economic liberty and freedom
and to you know
which seems to me to be very slippery i
mean you start talking about liberty
you're starting you know you think of
the all the coins started with liberty
but liberty meant something very
different
when the country was putting its roots
down than it did to the austrians in the
1940s 1950s
and
i don't
subscribe to the idea that liberty means
libertarianism i think libertarianism is
actually the direction that a lot of
those arguments go and that that's a
deadly dangerous idea point to me one
libertarian society that's ever worked
so i think i'm as all over the map as
that question was how am i doing am i
halfway through it yet halfway okay so
am i on to the democrats yet yeah okay
the occupy people want to know
why why are the republicans and the
democrats any different well again i
don't write about the democrats
and um i have my issues with the
democratic party as well but i think
that the problems with both of the
parties
come from different places
but what's really made things hard for
people to figure out nowadays is two
things one and they come from the same
position one is that beginning in 1968 i
think the book came out
um there was a redefinition of i was
called the emerging republican majority
a very famous book
that sliced and diced the electorate you
no longer had to have any themes you had
or ideas you had to get the left-handed
typists from duluth and you needed to
have you know the
miners from one county in arizona and
that instead of politics being about
ideas and concepts of the way the
country was going to go it became about
how many votes can i get onto my ticket
and once we started doing that we lost
political narratives and we lost
people's ability to identify viscerally
with a set of ideas one side or the
other and it's become very easy now
simply to destroy the other side by
saying well all you're interested in is
the right-handed type is from duluth and
they're both the exact same i actually
think fundamentally they're not the
exact same but they're at least one of
the parties and that would be the one
with the d by it has a really hard time
articulating
why it's different than the ours
okay we're quickly running out of time
so let's take maybe a a couple of
questions and we'll uh up here
and um give give heather a chance to to
respond why don't we work our way down
the table here maybe starting with
step up
hi i'm stanley falk
what happened to the republican party in
1872
when you had a group that split off
nominated horace greeley who was then
nominated by the democrats what was
going on there
you know this 1872 is such an important
year it really is it's such a great year
72
what happens in 72
quite literally is a fight between
charles sumner and and grant and charles
sumner wants to control the republican
party and he thinks he should he's
educated he's you know all those things
um
and he thinks grant is a backwards
bumpkin and grant thinks he's been i
don't know elected
and he um and that he knows what he's
doing and he cuts sumner out of a lot of
stuff
when he does that sumner and shirts
declare war on him now there's something
else going on there too and that's that
um
you've got to integrate the south back
into the into the union and in 18 the
summer of 1868 they've admitted um most
not all the southern states back to the
union under the omnibus bill to prove
that in fact the republicans are not
trying to control everything forever but
one of the states that is in terrible
trouble in 1870
is missouri
because missouri is a union state but it
is decimated by the war it's a true
guerrilla war there and missouri is
under what's called the drake
constitution of the draconian
constitution passed in 1865 that permits
no civic identity for anybody who has
ever sympathized in any way with the
confederacy which essentially means that
anybody who identifies as a democrat
can't vote can't hold office can't be a
minister can't be a pro minister
a
lawyer and can't be a teacher
once all the southern states are back in
the union the people in missouri the
democrats who can't vote
are pissed off
and they say this is not the society we
fought for and that's where carl schertz
comes from he comes from missouri and he
looks at these republican governments at
the republican government in missouri
that's keeping all the democrats out
and supporting grant and he goes to war
with both grant and that republican
party and that's
this internecine fight in missouri
becomes a national fight and
incidentally this is where we get the
idea that jesse james is an important
guy jesse james is a murderer and a
thief he's a thug
he's he is not any great hero but what
he is is a democrat in missouri who says
he is not guilty of anything he's
charged with
but he can't get a lawyer and he can't
get a jury because the juries are taken
from the poll lists and therefore he is
pers an individual being persecuted by
the republican government
those guys turn on grant
and
horace greeley's nomination in 72 by the
liberal republicans is very important
liberal because the idea the government
should be kept small and not be this
corrupt government
because it's a newspaper war the
sumner
shirts and pulitzer is working for
shirts at this point uh take over the
american newspapers and say that grant
is corrupt and that we need to take back
the american government and that's where
we get the idea that grant is corrupt
back to that the republican governments
are no more corrupt than any other
governments it's just that the
newspapers
are trying to destroy grant and but they
call them corrupt the studies say that
they're you know every government's got
its issues
all right let's take a couple more
questions a couple here and then a
gentleman and then we'll in many way i'm
bob oscar in many ways eisenhower sounds
more like a democrat than a republican
and i'm wondering to what extent
he chose to become a republican out of
expediency to to be elected or could he
have run as a democrat
and how would the democrats have reacted
to them okay hold on hold on uh the
gentleman right there and then we'll go
to the gentleman over there
is this a contest
i also had something uh to ask about
eisenhower
so maybe maybe i can add uh
so that you can combine your responses
um
i uh
i i i agree with you that eisenhower is
very admirable and uh and uh much
smarter than he led on to and as a
matter of fact of course a lot of
historians said that he pretended to be
bumbling and everything it was kind of
kind of a uh a ruse but um
did he think of himself as progressive i
mean
did he see himself in the tradition of
theodore roosevelt because of course in
your book you
cited modern republicanism uh by arthur
larson and eisenhower always liked to
use the term moderate and uh and i love
that quotation from april harriman that
moderation is not a term in the
democratic party uh
uh vocabulary so uh
how how
did eisenhower see himself in
relationship to theodore roosevelt was
he carrying on that tradition
consciously or not okay then a gentleman
the red sweater there
that's it
oh
uh yes um
i just have two questions and that is uh
how does the u.s constitution protect
property
specifically
and secondly i see that you go one you
go lincoln
theodore roosevelt
abraham uh to eisenhower but you don't
have reagan and i'm just wondering i
must say when i picked up the book and
started to read it i said what happened
to ronald reagan um he's got a chapter i
i got it that
that your your
um you know
sort of uh
three people there are important but
actually of the there's a fourth person
that's even more important than than
eisenhower certainly um and i don't see
him and i just wonder was that a
conscious decision or does that just
sort of happen did you introduce
yourself uh mike anderson i'm a retired
professor both at george basin in it
great northern virginia community
college okay wonderful thank
you doesn't someone want to throw in
daniel boone just to see if i can pull
them all together
eisenhower was asked to run by both
democratic and republican parties
um he ends up my
i think eisenhower
many historians say that in fact he was
only
posing when he said he didn't want to be
president but i actually think he didn't
want to be president even his private
writings say this is not a direction i
want to go where he wanted to go was
into the um into colombia the presidency
of the colombia where he which seems
weird except that he had worked so
closely
with uh his mentor who had taught him
all about
the importance of
a brain trust if you will academics
businessmen all sorts of people coming
together and plotting new courses to
come up with new ideas for the the new
century and he believed that the advent
of the nuclear weapon of the of the bomb
created a new century that had to be
answered
and that's
or a new problem new problems that had
to be answered and that's the way in
which he was most like teddy roosevelt
because teddy roosevelt took the idea of
the wisconsin plan
from
fighting bob lafollette the idea that
what you really need to do is bring your
bright guys together
and figure out how to attack a new world
now why he ends up being attack is the
wrong word how to negotiate a new world
how he ends up being a republican
instead of a democrat is first of all by
heritage i mean his uncle is named i
think his uncle is named abraham lincoln
eisenhower i mean you can't be
you can't come from kansas and texas and
not be
uh uh or kansas and not be a
a republican so there's that but there's
also the fact that he is terrified of
robert taft robert taft is an
isolationist and he um
is actually very much part of the the
group the the intractable group that i
was talking about they are known as the
taft republicans
and taft is adamant that the government
must not get involved in what he calls
stomach diplomacy overseas and
eisenhower believes as i say that if
the american government does not
actively
promote equality of opportunity around
the world
to undercut
dictatorial governments
there is going to be a nuclear war and
the earth is going to be destroyed he
believes this profoundly i mean it keeps
him up at night he's not messing around
and he gets very upset you can see it in
his speeches um for example in the
military industrial complex speech of 61
or you can see it in his speech the
press that i had up here
he keeps saying to people like taft and
mccarthy cut it out this is not a game
this is not a political game people are
going to die and i've seen them die you
people haven't and this must stop here
you know his visit to the order of
prison camp profoundly changed him and
he said you know we cannot we cannot
have this happen again
in human society
so he becomes a republican i think
because of that
um he doesn't trust the democrats either
he doesn't like spending the way the
democrats are doing but basically he has
no choice but to be republican although
the democrats just say ask him to run
good enough on on did i get both the the
eisenhower points
um i'm like a goldfish he's tripping
around the bulls brand new um
uh reagan why not reagan reagan's in
there but reagan is not in the tradition
that i consider the heart of the
republican party reagan is a direct line
as you know his a time for choosing
speech came in response to the goldwater
candidacy he was a democrat in his early
years but he switches in orange county
to becoming
a
fervently anti-communist republican
which is a really interesting thing
because in in california after world war
ii
because of the unique demographic
conditions the reason orange county
becomes so important is because you can
both stand against the welfare system
that is helping for example african
americans integrate into the schools in
little rock
or promoting uh systems in the south uh
racial equality in the south
and
still get enormous amounts of government
money by calling it anti-communism so
you're essentially having a welfare a
california welfare system for white
people and that's where we get the
military industrial complex that drives
eisenhower insane so it
i don't mean that literally he makes him
very unhappy so um so reagan is very
important but he's very important in the
selling
of this idea that the government must do
nothing except
promote big business christianity and at
that point promote a strong military now
interestingly enough i got into
an argument with somebody
when i said that
goldwater's conscience of a conservative
which is written by um by william f
buckley junior's brother-in-law albert
bissell who's still alive by the way um
that that document looked
very much like
the mud sill speech
and
that's not
rhetoric
and in fact i think it was some review
said sort of said well richardson says
this in the book about how they want to
turn the clock back to the days before
lincoln and implies that i made that up
in fact the line before that is a direct
quote my line that they that they quoted
was uh was a paraphrase of the previous
sentence because that's what they tell
us to do you know you you quote it and
then you say why you just quoted it
and um
um
that
speech i mean i'm sorry that pamphlet
the the um conscience of a conservative
does hark right back to the idea that
government should do absolutely nothing
that's the platform on except promote
big business christianity and the big
military that's the platform on which
barry goldwater runs in 64 and loses
everywhere except
arizona a right to work state one of the
few in the country only one in the
country i think at that time but don't
quote me on that one and the deep south
and
his most vocal supporter is ronald
reagan
in his a time for choosing speech he
goes on tv makes the end time for his
choosing speech and
at the time reporters say isn't it
astonishing the same stuff that when it
comes out of the mouth of
el bren bizzell sounds vicious and
horrible when it comes out of the new
republic sounds prayer isle sounds great
coming from him
and so reagan comes he's a great
salesman you know he's a great salesman
and very interesting man so he gets he's
in the book but in a very different
column than the drivers of it
lincoln roosevelt and eisenhower
i think we're out of time so well um
you'll have to um chat after um the
session the book is to make men free the
history of the republican party i think
we're all indebted to heather richardson
for a most learned afternoon
you're watching american history tv 48
hours of programming on american history
at